in the last hour you heard the hills
John Solomon tell us about Special
Counsel Bob Muller's possible conflict
of interest due to his ties to a Russian
oligarch John is now here with an even
newer breaking series of developments
that were just posted moments ago on the
hill nobody's heard this before it's
stunning stuff John what else should we
know I mean I I read through your piece
about a half hour ago when it was posted
now we find out that in September of
2016 that's right
Oleg Deripaska who's this guy made out
to be this big boogey man by the by the
political parties and by the you know in
our government on a sanctions list he's
visited by three FBI agents who want him
to do what yeah it's great so he's
already been very helpful to the FBI he
spent 25 million dollars of his own
money trying to help them rescue one of
their captured agents and Iran so he has
their trust they bring him into the
country because he had been banned from
coming in by the State Department they
give him eight or ten passports to come
in and then it's two months before the
election he's asleep in his apartment in
New York and he gets a knock on the door
by some of the same FBI agents that
worked with him on the earlier operation
they said we think Trump's campaign and
Russia are colluding on the election and
he lets out a big laugh wait wait wait
wait wait yeah
the agents say to a Russian billionaire
yes a close to Putin supposedly close to
Putin all the billionaires yeah it's
like all the billionaires and I'd say
it's no trumpeted all the politicians
like they always say that's like not a
big deal but they say to him we have an
idea or a theory that he's colluding
through what Paul Manafort all man
afford was the person they mentioned
they thought and and here's the funny
part
Oleg Deripaska had a tortured
relationship with Paul Manafort they
were he hired him as a political
consultant wasn't happy that gave him
some money for an investment Deripaska
sued him they had a falling-out he said
he stole my money took it into the
United States so the guy they go to is
an enemy of Paul manna for and they say
well can you help us prove that maybe
manna forts colluding with Putin to
throw the whole election to Donald Trump
and he laughs he breaks out in laughter
saying it's preposterous and they say no
seriously take this seriously you know
I'm telling you it's not true I don't
like the guys listen I love this Mirim
I'm telling you there's no chance at
Russia
using Paul Manafort to coordinate an
election and that's important for two
reasons it's two months before the
election it's before the FISA
application and here's someone that the
FBI trusted previously to give them
reliable information spend his own money
doing FBI work and now they're telling
you no collusion does the FISA Court
know this I bet not from a we a my
report and so our viewers understand
this we have a situation or three FBI
agents go to this Russian billionaires
apartment who only can come to the
United States because he's supposedly a
bad guy which by all indications he was
helping trying to help Bob Levinson get
out of Iran a 30-year veteran of the CIA
who we left there he tried to get him
out two times spent 25 million dollars
as you said had a jet waiting on the
tarmac pulled back by the State
Department for some weird reason Hillary
Clinton involved Barack Obama involved
perhaps even a previous administration
of that involved they go to him and they
say we have a collusion idea and he says
well that's ridiculous in and they then
say keep an open mind that's exactly
what they say they're trying to keep him
going
keeping Overmind let's stay in touch and
my reporting tonight they've been in
touch for quite a while now you have the
sources strong sources for this report
it's including Deripaska himself was on
the record and his lawyer as well as
several FBI agents in this story all
story that's well source I also
understand that Deripaska offered to
testify on Capitol Hill that's right I
have two sources on this offered to
testify did not ask for immunity it was
reported by the New York Times falsely
that he asked for immunity to testify
and also remember I think someone in
Congress also repeated that correct me
if I'm wrong so what are you not asked
for immunity why are they smearing this
guy it's like I'm you know why are they
smearing this particular person
I mean he's somebody who spent twenty
five million dollars trying to get that
Patriot Bob Levinson out of Iran yeah
there's a black hat white hat black hat
syndrome with him he's a bad guy for a
while father you treated that way then
he's a great guy I let him in the
country no problem then with the same
evidence that's been there all this time
now he's suddenly a bad guy again
but he's a good guy that they apparently
want
to push this collusion theory which if
he wanted to try to get off this
sanctions list yeah maybe he could have
said well yeah I'm sure yeah I'm sure
Paul manna for its colluding with with
some people some you know agents rogue
agents in Russia what can you give me he
didn't do that correct no he waved him
off it in the hard way okay let's bring
into this this guy is unbelievable it's
like a john lecarre a novel a retired
FBI Special Agent Tom Baker is here in
Washington and attorney Harmeet Dylan in
San Francisco guys these details are
moving fast and furious John Solomon has
done some of the most important
reporting on this case on Muller on the
FBI for months now and now this Tom I
want to start with you you knew Bob
Levinson going back to the first part of
this narrative you knew him you worked
with him when he I think he was at
counter-terror and you were at the FBI
and now we hear it with more details on
this Russian billionaire spending twenty
five billion dollars two times he had a
good handle on getting him out of the
country twice and he was waived off
twice and now they try to use them for
the collusion nonsense without outrage
well yes it is
it is and and what was an outrage in
that was the way the whole thing was was
waved off Bob Levinson died I crossed
rails with him a couple of times when we
were both involved in Russian organized
crime I happen to be at that time the
legal attache in Paris where Oleg
Deripaska often would stop by himself
actually he spent a lot of time in Paris
but Levinson we would try to do
everything we could to get every part of
the government moving on him I was
retired when he went missing we got very
little cooperation from the CIA and very
little cooperation from the State
Department and the FBI had to reach out
and do whatever they could themselves
now why is the FBI harm eight FBI is is
actually doing the work to try to get
the CIA guy out every Ron reaching out
and again I don't know if it's illegal
or not maybe but working with this guy
who had business interests in Iran
really rich really connected
and I bet Deripaska wanted to know why
the heck am I being banned from coming
to the United States show me the file
I'm such a bad guy show it to me and he
starts working with them like again
motivations aside that would have been a
great thing to get him out of the
country he State Department obscene act
a deal at the last moment for on some
it's seemingly spurious grounds go ahead
right well what we have learned from
Solomon's reporting is that you know
this was pulled off the table at the
last minute because Hillary Clinton
refused to say certain things that the
Iranian government wanted said in order
to point the finger away from them and
so you know that said this gentlemen and
most wealthy people in his position
don't do things out of necessarily the
goodness of their heart there would have
been an interest in it for him and
having good relations and ability to
come and go from the United States has
literally worth over ten billion dollars
to his businesses and so naturally he
wanted to help and do a good thing as
long as it didn't blow back on the
Russian government and so he was a short
of that he did what he was asked McCabe
was one of the people who recruited him
this is how he's thanked you know this
is how he's thanked he's now on you know
a sanctions list after by the way
refusing to quote unquote keep an open
mind when FBI agents visit him how do
you keep an open mind if you're asked
did a crime occur I mean keep an open
mind about it what does that mean that
is incredibly shady and suspect but you
know now we have a second instance here
Laura
of clearly the Department of Justice and
FBI not giving all the information to
the FISA Court because this is what we
would call a sculpt Ettore evidence of
in a criminal investigation where you
ask somebody did Manafort collude with
the Russians on behalf of the Trump
investigation Deripaska who would know
said absolutely not are you kidding me I
hate his guts he's cheating me in a
business deal but he didn't do that I am
quite certain as Solomon just said that
that was not revealed to the FISA Court
because if it were you know a judge
would take a second look at that and now
Manta Ford is fighting in court for
evidence of whether this is you know
even covered by the Rosenstein
authorization right and the and Muller
has filed that information under seal
again I think the fact that this
whole 25 million even talked about the
fact that the 25 million dollars
violates the anti-deficiency act of our
government where the government's not
allowed to take volunteer in from
support from citizens if it's not
authorized by Congress and so Muller may
be trying to cover that out because it
is embarrassing to him that he violated
the law we're gonna can stay on this
thank you harm me and Tom welcome back
we're continuing our discussion with
Hill reporter John Solomon on the big
story he just broke special prosecutor
Bob Muller may be tainted by a conflict
of interest in the Russia probe let's
also bring in former FBI agent Robin
grits in Chicago now Robin supervised
the Levinson case back in 2009 if you
just tuned in Bob Levinson 30-year
veteran of the CIA held now for 11 years
in Iran we learn more details tonight
about the efforts of a Russian
billionaire Oleg Deripaska now on the US
sanctions list to secure his release on
two different occasions spending 25
million dollars and now we learn that
Oleg Deripaska was approached by the FBI
in September of the election year
September 2016 where they floated an
idea of well mana for it might be
colluding with Trump and what do you
think about that he's like I don't even
like mana for that that's the the facts
are ridiculous the intense ridiculous
that's absurd and the FBI basically said
keep an open mind that's wild Robin I
want to go to you of course you are on
this Levinson case from the beginning
now we're learning more about how this
effort was strung along shut down at
least on one occasion now by Hillary
Clinton your thoughts tonight as these
new developments are coming in when John
gave me a call about what he was finding
out I was I was shocked I I had taken
over the case about seven months after
Bob was arrested by the Iranian
authorities and we were turning over
every stone to bring him back and
working with a whole-of-government
approach to bring him back and now I
hear after I left the case that
there was actually a plane on the tarmac
and because of some changes in a
statement the agreement went downhill
and Bob's remained in in Iran and I
think it's still there today yeah well
if we we hope he's still alive I mean he
was mm-hmm maybe 80 years old today but
we think John Solomon we don't leave a
man behind
if at all possible we don't leave a man
behind and in this case he was he was
left behind and he had the FBI and
McCabe trying to I guess trying to be
creative about your posture your posture
by the way had had conversations with
John McCain do we know what those
conversations were about years ago I do
it's a story I broke at the Washington
Post
ten years ago trying to find out about
policy what the president would
president might be for heaven forbid we
actually try to find out what what the
current US government is all about but
getting back to the conflict of interest
Alan Dershowitz and Jonathan Turley had
interesting comments let's first look at
what Jonathan Turley said about all this
he's concerned about a potential
conflict he said if the operation with
Deripaska contravened federal law this
figure could be viewed as a potential
embarrassment for Muller the question is
whether he could implicate Muller it
could implicate Muller in an impropriety
and then Alan Dershowitz saying this he
also had similar concerns about a
potential conflict I think we have the
full screen he said the real question
becomes whether it was proper to leave
him Deripaska out of the mana Ford
indictment and whether that omission was
to avoid a kind of transparency that is
really required by the law yeah I mean I
talked to four or five legal experts
they all had the same assessment they
come from all different political
viewpoints very similar let's think
about something you said something
really powerful we don't leave any men
behind think about how desperate the FBI
had to be to go to a Russian Oleg art
and say could you fund this because the
United States government would in front
of the Obama administration the State
Department the CIA would not go back and
get their own man to the level that the
FBI thought it deserved so they go and
reach out to this guy and they after
they have to fund an extracurricular
activity to rescue one of our own men I
think that
one of the saddest parts of this tale
that gets overlooked and Hillary Clinton
obviously as Secretary of State tell me
about her potential and what we know is
from the family so Dave McGee the lawyer
for the family told us on the record
that they had a deal Deripaska came back
they were sending the plane to the
tarmac we're gonna rescue him there was
a statement that the Iranian government
wanted basically saying we really
weren't involved in it and Hillary
Clinton was unwilling to give him that
sort of absolution and the deal fell
apart plane left and he was never
rescued you got you gotta say I mean you
kind of have to say what you got to say
at that point to get I mean some stupid
statement to Iran I mean who cares I
mean Robin to me that's just that
nothing you you wonder if there was any
future concern about any Iran deal down
the road I mean yes I don't know what
was going into play but then you fast
forward Robin to do the fall of 2016 now
some of these agents agents who
approached Deripaska in his apartment in
New York remember he's only allowed to
come into the United States on a few
occasions one by one visa they
approached him and they say to float
this collusion idea and and he's like
what collusion but this man afford it
he's like kind of laughing at them and
they're like no keep an open mind so
they were actually trying to collude
with the Russian billionaire to push the
Russian collusion theory Robin it's
outrageous that all this is going on
it's like it's stuff that you see in the
movies and to see that people that were
working for the release of Robert
Levinson have now switched and are
actually pushing a political agenda and
and you said something really
interesting about Hillary Clinton and
then the Iran deal and when I I actually
was gone from the FBI when the Iran deal
was signed and I was waiting for Bob's
name to be read I was waiting for him to
come home and when his name wasn't read
I just it heartbreaking because I I want
to clarify that bob was actually an FBI
agent for that amount of time he was
also a DEA agent
he was just like any of us when we leave
at service we we contract with people
and yes he was contracting with one
agency but he was talking to a lot of
people I'm having them you know all the
kids and everything and yeah you know
it's just the family the family has been
through hell and now they're suing Iran
I'm telling you John I think Republicans
on the hill if it's not gonna be
Democrats Republicans should call
Deripaska to Washington he's offered to
testify without immunity don't lie and
say he asked for immunity because he
didn't bring him up to the hill hear
what he has to say question him sharply
question him you don't have to trust
what he said
question him I think the American people
would like to know a little bit more
about about keeping the boogeyman of the
Russian billionaire is alive you know
keep the big fantasy alive fantastic
reporting Robin thank you for what you
you've done for your service to this
country
all those years John Solomon please keep
us up to date on your reporting
fantastic reporting any any news from
Muller did Muller respond to your the
proverbial no comment for verbal no
comment we appreciate it
of course